[Musique]
la semaine dernière que peut-être un
espoir du cinéma était un nouveau cinéma
est-ce que vous dont le nom est associé
monsieur venait à tous les cinémas
français muet et parlant qui avait
tourné je crois plus disons plus de 200
films oui à peu près je dire qu'il faut
dire 200 parce que j'ai commencé une
époque où on tournait un grand film dans
en trois jours j'ai commencé en 1908 et
bien précisément maintenant on met très
longtemps beaucoup plus de temps pour
faire un grand film parce que les
problèmes techniques ont évolué parce
qu'il ya un certain progrès ont tout cas
une évolution du slim est ce que cette
machine cinématographique vous semble
maintenant mettre à la disposition du
comédien des moyens plus sérieux pour
exprimer la vérité humaine qu'à sa
propre naissance
oui et non oui non parce que les moyens
sont certainement beaucoup plus
perfectionnés et ed
en somme mais d'autre part la technique
empêche le comédien d'être absolument
libre et débarrassé de de tous qui
l'entourent
alors ça sent bon son mauvais côté il me
semble que si l'on voit le votre
carrière vous avez fait du théâtre est
actuellement vous êtes uniquement un
homme de cinéma
est-ce que quelquefois cette chaleur de
l'applaudissement du spectacle ne vous
gêne pas ce choix est il des libérés ou
est-ce momentanée non il est certain que
le public est beaucoup
c'est ce qui manque au cinéma dont on
parlait moyen d'expression
son lui-même est-ce que puisque vous
parlez de ses moyens d'expression pour
vous non pas pour le comédien général
mais pour vous un personnage est une
mécanique à mettre au point où un état
d'âme à trouver ou pour reprendre une
formule pour vous faut-il vivre un
personnage ou faut-il le faire vivre à
l'écran
je pense qu'il faut le vivre
j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec gémier dans
le temps où théâtre et j'ai mis ma dit
un jour une phrase qui en somme mais la
clé de tout le métier lecteur m'a dit il
faut penser ce que tu dis est pas à ce
que tu dis vous avez exactement répondu
d'une façon très belle et cela m'amène à
vous demander si aujourd'hui où de
nouveaux et de jeunes comédiens entrent
dans le jeu si vous avez l'impression
que à bord de ce métier d'une façon
différente si des rencontres
je pense par exemple à la rencontre
difficile de gabin delon dans un film
nous allons ici avec symphony plan
massacre vous voir au côté de jean
rochefort et dans peu de temps nous
allons voir un autre film vous êtes avec
un autre jeune comédien qui est belmondo
comment vous monsieur vanel vivez vous
ces rapports ces dialogues et cette vie
de métier avec ses jeunes comédiens se
met jamais changé il ya toujours eu des
vieux et des jeunes
le métier aussi bien au théâtre au
cinéma alors ça dépend de la mentalité
du du talent des jeunes avec belmondo
par exemple et rochefort
ça va tout seul ce sont de vrais acteurs
donc il ne peut pas dire d'après vous
que cette évolution du cinéma que vous
avez si bien souligné se trouve sur le
plan des comédiens où chacun va avec
toute son âme comme vous êtes allez vous
même mais il n'y a pas de modification
dans l'esprit dans la façon dont on
aborde ce métier non je ne crois pas
[Musique]